well I insist on an eye for an eye when
the IU lost is now a sick looking
gemstone Eamonn targaryen's sparkly New
Look is thrilling House of the Dragon
fans here's why the season one finale of
House of the Dragon saw princess
rhaenyra and Damon return to Dragonstone
soon after princess rhaenice arrives and
informs the two of King viserys's death
Allison's subsequent usurpation of the
throne and the crowning of aegon II is
King both targaryens are rightfully
angry with Damon calling for an all-out
war against the greens but rhaenyra
keeps a cool head instead of jumping
straight to battle which could see many
Innocents die she sends envoys to secure
alliances with house Tully Stark and
Baratheon her eldest son jacaris travels
to house Tully before heading north to
confirm Hal Stark's Allegiance meanwhile
rainer's younger son luceras travels the
storm's end to secure an alliance with
house Baratheon and it's there where the
finale dialed it up Luke arrives at
Storm's end only to see the dragon
Veigar already there as he enters the
Baratheon Hall he's greeted by his uncle
Eamon Targaryen who seems to have
already secured barabian Alliance
through a marriage pact did you really
think that you could just fly about the
realm
trying to steal my brother's Throne at
no cost
before leaving Eamonn demands Luke cut
out his eyes retribution for him losing
his own eye years ago Eamonn then
removes his eye patch revealing the
sapphire he has in place of the eye he
lost the loop when they were kids
while House of the Dragon has plenty of
differences from Source material Fire
and Blood fans were pleased that Eamonn
Sapphire I made it to the show the
reveal left many viewers surprised and
their reactions on social media tell you
all you need to know while eamon's
Fantastical replacement for his eye is
very on par with George R.R Martin's A
Song Of Ice And Fire series Game of
Thrones tended to dull down many of the
more eccentric appearances of characters
from the books so the reveal left many
viewers surprised after the finale
Twitter blew up with fans talking about
Eamonn his eye and his questionable
actions at perfectly set up season two
one fan posted Eamon Sapphire I reveal
was so sick the discussion also made its
way over to Reddit on a house of the
Dragon thread the verdict the eye is
indeed sick one user wrote I gotta say
Eamon Sapphire eye looks sickest
another agreed posting yes I immediately
said to my husband why doesn't he stop
wearing the eye patch that thing looks
badass others took the opportunity to
praise you and Mitchell for his betrayal
of aemond like one user who simply
stated the actor is perfect for the role
others commented that they wanted to
hate Eamonn but I didn't cool Sapphire
ride and Mitchell's already excellent
performance left them captivated by the
character instead like in the show Fire
and Blood introduces aemond as the third
born child of King viserys Targaryen and
Alison Hightower his early childhood is
represented accurately in House of the
Dragon including being the last child to
bond the dragon while he grows up
thinking that gaining Vega are made up
for him losing an eye he still resents
Rainier as children for taking the Iron
Throne from him and his brother aegon II
in House of the Dragon the events at
storm sand more or less played out the
way they did in the book but there are a
few differences minor book spoilers
ahead some small details at the show
left out included Eamonn being taunted
by one of Boris baratheon's daughters
after luceris ignored his uncle's
threatening words further inciting
eamon's actions against his nephew in
the book while Boris doesn't allow
violence within his walls he tells amen
that he has no say in what happens
outside of Storm's end one larger change
from The Source material is that Eamonn
purposefully kills lucerus and his
dragon air ax whereas in House of the
Dragon Veigar disobeys amen making
lucerus's death more or less an accident
though as the showrunner Ryan Condell
pointed out to Vanity Fair no one could
have known what was actually going on in
eamon's head when the maesters were
writing the history of the war and Fire
and Blood so this interpretation isn't
wronged or right it's just another way
the showrunners have made this story
their own
[Music]